candidat emblématique de la saison une
et on se souvient tous de ce duo
forcément
écoutez moi
[Musique]
je t'en prie
je te jure
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
alors personnellement moi perso j'en
conviens pas changé alors moi j'ai
qu'une question de basquiat je t'aime
énormément humainement mais comment tu
t'es retrouvé dans une émission de
chansons
c'est sûr que c'est de la chance pour
nous tu crois
[Rires]
le plus fort ce que le public a accroché
mais parce que - ont toujours voté pour
moi donc consulté peut-être le fait que
je me prenne pas au sérieux et que je
fasse le condom comme audi se retrouver
là ta posture et ben non j'ai pas
poursuivre et on est venu me chercher
j'étais sur une plage moi j'étais
pompier en plage du côté de
saint-jean-de-luz bien est ce que tu
connais bien oui on est venu me chercher
en disant voilà ce que tu vas faire un
jeu où il faut chanter à la télé donc
j'ai cru à une blague au départ et puis
de cette blague c'est devenu une énorme
blague d'éditer le bios hâter le beau
gosse a wave le bec ça me permettre
heureusement qu'il était là parce que
franchement ça a mis l'ambiance moi tu
m'étonnes
iris est impliqué franchement en plus
hitchcock bam la plus belle jennifer oui
ok
karine magnifique aussi mais là plus
près on va dire et me voilà jennifer
s'est bien passé le géniteur très bien
passé vous voyez encore tu vas pas du
tout non pas du tout du tout non plus
côté s'il a rappelé dans ce numéro que
tu veux non je n'ai après d'ailleurs
j'ai pas de baisser c'est bien qu'elle
devait se comporter avec ses ex quand
même moi je la page apparaît si j'avais
me suis pas sûr qu'elle va me revoir non
plus aux ordres mais ça c'est pas on
avec un truc sympa c'était très bien
j'ai fait une choix de carrière vous
êtes revenu l'été dernier pour
l'instrument tf1 s'est vu très vite way
sur la jccm a passé bon on l'a vu juste
le temps d'enregistrement donc on n'a
pas eu trop le temps
l ouest archers pas là beaucoup de
boulot quoi donc d'accord on l'a vu vite
fait brièvement voilà mais c'était très
bien et fait une belle carrière est
réussi et tant mieux pour elle et elle
le mérite et forcément souviens toi
parce qu'un jour tu peux tu es plus le
château tu décides de partir voilà qui à
londres alors tu es une anecdote la
douane qu'une anecdote je suis dans le
bureau de la directrice alex alors
joubert qui me dit jean pascal qu'est ce
qui se passe j'en ai marre je me casse
jaune et bleu tu de ce jeu je m'en vais
bon écoute ok il faut que tu te reposes
tu vas partir quelques jours se mettre
au vert j'ai dit ok je vais chez moi
elle me dit non partout sauf en france
et moi nb si le coeur je suis un peu
londres tu sais petit mec du sud est
peut-être ce voyage aux lieux dire cuba
ah ouais il est je suis parti c'est très
joli lormes oui il a plus de quatre
jours comme ça qu'on verra sur les
images mais j'en garde un bon souvenir
seul à londres et quand tu reviens en
prime sont des gens qui décident de
garder ça c'est exceptionnel le public a
été depuis depuis 20 ans le public c'est
chaque jour mais vrai pour que tu
voulais arrêter c'est génial comme
histoire c'est très particulier comme un
psychologiquement quand même comme
expérience pourquoi il ya un moment où
il ya des coups dans le château on est
on est entre nous c'est une bulle donc
envie qu entre nous donc il ya des coûts
de certaines psychologiquement c'est
difficile en a qu'une minute du
téléphone dans les coupes et c'est il
faut pas craquer et moi humainement
puisque en plus moi je suis entier je
craque souvent ça arrive j'ai dit je
m'en vais parce que ça va j'ai pas je
suis pas chanteur c'est pas mon job
qu'est ce que je fais c'est parce que
nous extérieurement mais nous c'est
vraiment ce qu'on voit c'est ce que je
veux montrer maintenant c'est vous
chantez avec des stars qu'on ne compte
pas d'âge il ne reverra plus est jamais
allé frapper à l'essai par ne ment
jamais vu mois plus tôt mais chanteur
florent pagny mes idoles qui ont été là
mais avec tout le monde mais tout seul
avec une star
on a toujours je jure que je vais
t'arranger sage et de faire venir une
star ici à bévilard ou n'importe quoi tu
vas chanter avec je te jure mais
regardez regardez comme les stars qui
veut
le pass comme un sport dispose
[Musique]
hier
non
[Musique]
michael dubie requête des fois c'est que
non si ils sont tous là c'est
normalement le retour je dis bien
normalement le retour de cette émission
est prévue pour septembre octobre sur
tf1 7 durer entre huit et neuf semaines
il aurait travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec la star ac au canada
justement parce que là bas la directrice
et lara fabian regardez c'est lara
fabian qui a irrité de la star de la
star ac qui a mis ko 6 qui est très qui
est très présent dans l'astarac regarder
auquel la version canadienne post mortem
ont pas jeter un regard rempli
d'empathie d' analyse mais aussi de
réflexion sur tout ce qu'on a vécu ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
félicitations vraiment je propose qu'on
regarde un numéro d'ouverture
[Musique]
à
quant à lui
[Musique]
alors ça c'est pas des blagues samedi
depuis 2000 21 c'est la troisième saison
c'est un énorme carton et c'est à cause
de ça que tf1 s'est dit mais c'est un
carton au canada pourquoi on le relance
serait battu les stars américaines les
grosseurs américaines vont sur le
plateau du prime et tout bah oui mais
forcément c'est plus près pour elles
mais elles le font bien sûr mais genre
bien que c'est pour elle c'est un oui
mais bien d'y être
nous avions aussi réglé nous coûte 400
milles bas de les faire venir bientôt
c'est un peu compliqué donc on a l'âme
alors ce que je veux dire aussi c'est
que donc les profs sont des stars comme
par exemple mika qui est prof là bas a
donc il compte changer tous les profs
oscar sisto n'aurait pas été appelé pour
cette nouvelle non vous n'êtes voilà
nico sera accompagné du co animatrice
peut-être peut-être je dis bien
peut-être que mario serait le répétiteur
des élèves peut-être que l'uci pour
intégrer le casting est peut-être que la
prod sont en train de faire nécessaire
pour tourner l'émission au château de
dammarie-lès-lys y est pour l'instant
s'occupe de mariage voilà donc à pas mal
de gens qui sont appelés si on va pas
tout dire parce qu'un acquis sont même
autour de la table corps a été contacté
pour être pions pour être directeur
plaidera là on va pas tout dire tout ce
que je peux dire c'est si vous étiez
contacté pour voir un rôle dedans est ce
que vous accepteriez et tous les uns les
autres oui oui oui si une pareille 7
points tant qu'élève je sais pas non aux
élèves non mais surtout demandé d'être
plus est prof ou d'être pions ou d'être
d'abord d'avoir un rôle dans le deuil
masterclass tu le ferais aussi une
masterclass pourquoi pas mais après je
pense que je pense pas avoir la
légitimité
était malade ou quoi débuts comme tu
saisis non non je me dis sérieusement je
pense que je finale ça serait étudiée
mais on m'a pas appelé donc nous
pardon les filages est un tout petit peu
me gallant mais je m'intéressais aussi
parce qu'il ait l'air de dire que
franchement il n'a pas dit n'a pas de
talent finaliste de la saison 2 face à
la loi nauroy
sympathique de la bande en plus
d'anciens hyper bien vous aviez tous les
talents pour moi vous étiez beau vous
dansiez père bien j'étais beau à voir
non mais vous
changer
les idées des moments évidemment il ya
eu des duos il est moment très touchant
aussi c'est quand bouts de fils débarque
sur le bateau de lattara crème des
amériques
je m
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
rico
[Musique]
loulou
[Applaudissements]
malgré la chaleur
l'interconnection question vous posez
nous aussi c'est la star ac de revenir à
la rentrée ces voix là c'est des moments
comme ça et je pense que le public était
très friand mais c'est pour ça et on l'a
vu aux vingt ans qu'on a fait danser
ensemble qui a eu une euphorie dans les
audiences ou dans le public et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut que ça revienne la
star ac parce que c'est un vrai
programme qui rassemble mais
qu'apportent des émotions est qui et qui
manque je crois aujourd'hui à la télé
c'est pour ça qu'on peut se passer
aujourd'hui
on est plutôt malin nous fournit des
tomates yadio que j'aimerais vous de
montres montré que phil collins
en effet après mais promis quelque chose
pendant la pub vous m'avez dit comme
jean pascal ne chante pas parce qu'ils
aient fait marrer ce crime est odieux
mois moi je peux chanter parce que je
t'aime mathieu ah oui moi aussi je
t'aime houcine merci maintenu mais
d'abord avec phil collins regarde
d'accord
je
[Musique]
défendons
franchir
[Musique]
j'adore je vais
et
je ferai pour toi c'était toute une
chanson ça a été une rencontre vous avez
beau ça ensemble après il a écrit des
chansons c'est hallucinant quand même
huawei ccd tous les artistes qui sont
venus sur le plateau c'est vraiment mon
plus beau tuyaux mon plus beau souvenir
et puis puis c'est un être humain
exceptionnel c'est pas mariah carey qui
avait fait qu'après sa georges alain
qu'on n'a jamais revu et jean-georges
free party avec mariah carey non je sais
bien mais
je crois que je ferais qu avec jennifer
lopez s'était pas où il a eu toutes les
stars ouais c'était spécial avec vieilli
faire ou quoi ce que ben nikos annonce
qu'il faut que je prenne l'avion le
lendemain d'ailleurs j'ai eu la chance
de faire le dernier vol du concorde donc
je suis arrivé face à jean bernier
raison et justement
parce que le dernier tu serais moi
et là j'arrive en dit non qu'est ce que
tu portes elle n'aime pas donc il faut
changer de vêtements mais qu'on me
ramène des vagues ensuite on dit tu vas
monter sur scène elle va arriver tu ne
la regarde pas tu regardes au dessus de
son épaule j'avais pris profil et tu
récites ontex elle va te répondre mais
non c'était match quoi et la non non
c'est nagui c'est hallucinant quand même
voilà donc on dépasse y plus de temps
ensemble et ça a été ouverte et grosses
complicité du coup n'ont même pas le
droit tu vas le mec me dit son manager
me dis si elle tombera cette unité je
fais comment donc sans qu'elle vienne me
fais la bise donc je je tente quelque
chose on sait ainsi faire moi j'ai vécu
ça et bruno mars quand j'ai fait la star
ac a pas marché la dernière pardon
c'est la classe et succès et bruno mars
dans sa loge et je frappe à la loge dit
bonjour ou non chez les mateurs eux
est-ce qu'on pourrait se parlait déjà
est-ce que vous pourrez se parler de
minutes et fait rêver de photo et me dit
non je mangeais vidéo bas mais ils
perdent la porte au nez très bien on
arrive derrière le rideau gib.a bruno
c'est toujours moi parce qu'on pourra
faire un petit selphy nos temps de sa
mère le rideau dessous je présente bruno
mars qui était odieux depuis le début
des répétitions et là pendant qu'ils
chantent elles me suis bien côté j'ai
des tirages selphy connard
[Applaudissements]
hélas odieux
doit bien regretter maintenant comme il
a vu que ma carrière a
et les sommets et est-ce que parmi vous
quatre jeunes a eu justement avec qui ça
c'est pas très très bien passés d'eads
est pas des moins bons souvenirs avec
des stars américaines je n'ai pas eu
donc pas non voilà on dire elle a été la
première n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'internationaux et milton jeunes
messieurs le teint de jeune quand même
si on a une britney le bas là c'était le
début a eu ils ont tout ce qu ils ont
obligé la totale oui à chavez stevie
wonder
nous sommes au début céline dion oui ça
s'est passé c'était très bien ça elle
m'a sauvé la vie a un clanwar parce que
j'étais pas très bien j'ai eu un petit
problème de santé au moment du prime mon
micro ne marche pas ouais je n'entends
rien je vois tout public qui se lève et
je la chante et s'il suffisait d'aimer
fera sahel et c'est une catastrophe et
je vois je la voit se lever et me tendre
son micro et je vous dis mais je me sens
mais qu'est ce qu'elles veulent et donc
du coup je reprends la chanson mais
c'était très très pénibles parce que je
savais pas du tout où j'en étais et elle
me prend dans ses bras elle me fait ce
gros câlins elle me parle à l'oreille
mais elle m'a dit des choses que je ne
me souviens pas finalement parce que
j'étais sous redressent que j'avais
vraiment les oreilles et mais c'était un
super moment car j'étais enfin je me
suis dit oh là là j'ai tout gâché et en
fait ça a été un les plus redoutés de
tir touche en se déchargeant ces lignes
on était traitée très touchante pendant
toute la star ac toi je te dis quand
même je me réjouis avec bruel mais
attends tu connaissais brûle pas à redon
est avec qui j'ai raté de jérémy oui ah
oui mais qu'ils étaient en couple oui
c'est un beau souvenir ça oui il est
depuis en couple non ça fait longtemps
ouais on parlait encore we had regrets
alors oui c'est sûr alors pas d'enfants
cachés ah non
alors on passa vidéo est parti regarde
[Musique]
l'histoire
je voulais
sondés
[Musique]
les
mais je te le dis comme
[Musique]
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
elle
alors on va changer moss et à menominee
encore
ouais ça vous touche encore que vous
voyez ça ou pas du tout je les ai vus
150 fois donc c'est vrai que je suis
habitué mais je me souviens des
sensations des regards qu'on avait et
c'est un moment qu'on attendait depuis
très longtemps et j'ai adoré ce moment
avec vous êtes marié je suis pas que
c'est oui avec avec jérémy avec un
enfant j'en ai deux de quelle rencontre
du zambien tôt et 50 à plomber
l'ambiance
que tu leur a montré ses extrêmes pas du
tout oui oui il était même ils sont
venus avec moi sur le tournage des vingt
ans et c'était dans l'est dans les loges
ils étaient surexcités ils connaissent
pas du tout la star ac ne connaissent
que maman qui qui qui chantent et c'est
vrai que c'était particulier pour eux
parce qu'ils regarder les images il ya
mais maman tu as eu une vie en fait
avant nous c'est si vous voulez faire
eux mêmes de ce genre d'émission tu
dirais quoi je dirais oui je le
protégerai je leur expliquerai beaucoup
beaucoup de choses mais c'est tellement
moi ça m'a changé la vie et je pense
qu'on est tous
on a vécu des moments tellement fort
mais vous continuez à chanter tous les
trophées à tous les trois
mois je vais pas te vexer
pas acquise à michel maes que vous
continuez à chanter tous les quatre les
amis oui désolé je peux vous en êtes
exactement
avant de confinement j'avais monté un
plateau star ac comme back du coup qu'il
n'avait pas pris de départ et qui a
débuté le 17 avril d'accord il ya
quelques jours voilà avec une multitude
de dates qui arrive le 4 juin le tronc
tle 24 juin
bonsoir l'avenir ben écoutez c'est un
peu moi je suis très nostalgique de star
ac alors que tous deux voient ce sont
des culs et le public aussi on a eu on
en a eu la preuve là
la semaine il ya quelques jours et du
coup le public est au rendez vous on
vous connaît encore dans la rue tous les
quatre oui
j'ai une question sur le côté télé
réalité de l'époque et je leur ai parlé
à wil fait maintenant parce que c'était
quand même une télé réalité aussi il
faut le rappeler - le nom mais on vous
voyait au quotidien et avait une
quotidienne qui marchait super bien on
attendait toute la semaine pour vous de
découvrir sur le prime et où c'était
vraiment très très fort aujourd'hui je
pense pas que la nouvelle star ac pourra
vivre maintenant comme ça je me rappelle
qu avait des chemins parfois je me
souviens toi par exemple tu étais un peu
choqué par une certaine emma daumas qui
flirtent ou ya un petit peu avec
quelqu'un dans le château alors qu'elle
avait un mec en dehors et c'est ce que
je vous en parlais beaucoup d'entre vous
et est ce que le côté justement un peu
télé réalité pouvait poser des problèmes
en fait parfois entre les uns et les
autres alors parce que vous saviez que
les caméras étaient là honnêtement
moi je fais la différence vraiment entre
ce que vous appelez de télé réalité de
notre temps et la télé réalité
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que nous on
avait un système c'est système de karma
caméra remote qui sont là dans les
plafonds et non des convives et notre
vie donc après moi j'ai vraiment vécu ça
comme une grosse colonie de vacances à
savoir qu'on est des enfants à un tel
sort avec untel untel fréquent des intel
font serment s'en fout aujourd'hui la
télé réalité c'est vous êtes dans une
pièce jouée le cadreur qui à côté de
nous à côté de nous il ya le journaliste
et c'est ça qui qui qui crée le chemin
de ce qu'on appelle cette télé réalité
où on dit que tout est écrit tout et moi
je fais vraiment une différence et je
vois plutôt star ac comme une émission
de divertissement et de variété comme du
temps de sacrée soirée champs elysées
c'est comme ça que j'ai perçu en tout
cas nos star academy et pas du tout
comme une théorie équipe et je pense que
si ce programme revient
si le système de chaîne 24 h/24 revenez
qu'on ne tomberaient pas dans cet hymne
dance est l'idée est surtout de la
question qui tue et après je l'enlève
d'accord mais après est ce qui m
intéresse à vous parce que vous êtes mon
idole mais on a encore beaucoup de temps
mais quand vous voyez les nolwenn les
les quais qui avait derrière génisses r
wen elodie projets des frais j'ai tout
ça est ce que vous dites pas il ya eu
une petite forme d'injustice il ya il ya
un truc a merdé est-ce que vous des
papilles voilà pour moi et pas nous
parce que le public a voté la non mais
au delà du vote mais la suite mais la
suite non la suite pas bonjour parce que
je sais pas si on va sur le long et on
est signé chez universal le même label
mercury par saison il ya neuf artistes
ouais est ce que le label a le temps de
développer neuf artistes nahon sachant
que l'année d'après il ya une nouvelle
saison qui vient que vous vous avez
sorti votre gueule mais vous ne pouvez
pas venir sans plateau faire la
promotion parce qu'on fait de l'ombre à
la saison qui arrive juste derrière donc
qu'avant monde et il faut faire des
choix prendre le recul grandir et puis
faire son chemin et est là et la star
academy cessé de la musique mais ce
n'est pas que de la musique c'est pour
ça qu'elles les cours de théâtre
absolument il ya parce qu'il ya des gens
qui peuvent sortir qu'ils peuvent faire
de la fiction de faire du théâtre quand
ça c'est un truc un peu dépressif
derrière quotas pas gagné justement avec
universal est d'intéresser un peu moins
à thouars foot bien entouré c'est tout
ouais c'est tout voilà exactement faut
savoir accepter que ce n'est que de la
télé il faut savoir prendre des chemins
différents alors karine karine quand
même des plus belles voix de la saison
une hallucinante sera pas de son dur
notamment avec lara fabian on va
l'écouter elle est vraiment demandé qui
était qui
[Musique]
mais bon
jean
[Musique]
j'y crois
c
[Applaudissements]
c'est là moi fais là moi j'y crois
encore nous avons fait la gamme est
large cette chanson par ailleurs sur wii
elle ne pleurait pas il ménage
[Musique]
mais basique mais
je crois encore vivant quand on est fort
merde
juste leur faim oui à toutes les
chansons
à tout jamais jusqu'à là
non
ça c'est rien céder pour hbo sexuelle
beaucoup il veut retourner
et alors
et hélas après après est ce que tu te
dirait que tu perds un peu ou pas après
tu fais une comédie musicale et un peu
de télé réalité ça alors moi honnêtement
je me suis pas perdus du tout non non
c'est vraiment pas mais en fait moi j'ai
kiffé ouais t'as kiffé ou à mais
vraiment moi je suis j'étais vraiment
passionnés la musique donc en fait que
ce soit que ça cartonne longtemps que je
chantais sais pas pourquoi je garde
parce que tu es avec jean 2
en fait tant que je chantais j'étais
heureuse et que j'apprenais mon métier
que je partageais ce moment là avec des
gens moi j'ai appris mon métier à la
comédie musicale aussi par la suite avec
patsy gallant marais aide quand même moi
c'est quand même bon voilà la masia jay
les petits clover et en tout plus vils
publie de tout ça aujourd'hui tu en
viens là j'avais vécu pendant 17 ans
d'accord il s'est en partie aux états
jean xxii pas
et voilà je suis revenu et j'ai monté
une entreprise
dans le home staging dans le bâtiment
j'ai arrêté là et en fait je pense que
j'arrivais un cap à un tournant où j'ai
envie de faire autre chose moi en fait
dès que je fais quelque chose une fois
que je suis arrivé au bout je suis une
passionnée en fait on peut pas atteindre
cet argent pas genre houcine karine ça à
peu près ça vous a rapporté combien la
star academy
je suis là j'ai dû prendre trois cent
mille balles à peu près bravo et merci
jean pascal j'ai toujours dit on parlait
librement exactement car ils ont comparé
des sacrés [ __ ] de rentiers à sa fille
karine
karine silla
karin viard est je suis la faune ouais
c'est ce qui a été dit karine c'est
mathieu macarena mille cinq cents
500 milles mais comment tu fais à prix
fondent en discute
c'est que cette histoire is in jeune
papa jalal a aussi entendu chanter
génial
tu me parles passait bien
entre nous on n'en a gagné que moi
et toi vous compte arrêter la chanson
pop art est totalement dans la comédie
ne baisse que j'étais pas une super
chanteuse déjà de base est que pas grave
je sais pas moi oui c'est vrai la géante
et bien et que oscar sisto avait noté
quelque chose de talent tu rends toi
c'est ça je n'avais pas car si ce tome à
tulle avait pas de
problème alors et d'ailleurs oscar
allons à lui le c'est vrai que la
première le premier cours que vous avez
donnée dans l'astarac alexia laroche
joubert qui nous a dit c'est un massacre
il faut tout recommencer non mais c'est
pas le mot mais des copies je suis
tout temps mais bisang été choisie
pendant au milieu d'eux parmi 60
personnes donc de ce petit accent
allemand ça a aidé par comme un malade
enfin j'entends c'est
l'argentine l'allemagne et des pays
voisins et rémois s'est très
et même quand vous dites kindergarten
c'est l'allemand qui nous regardent
abbassi qui ne gardent un événement
et vous pas la louper
ça veut dire aussi la ville la ville des
anges donc
mais
je me souviens avoir dit à alexia que je
voulais pas assister au prime pourquoi
parce que moi je voulais être faire du
théâtre avec eux d'après midi et partir
d'accords dont vous était un petit peu
le celui qui poserait ses conditions
elle adore cd non mais je ne voyais pas
l'intérêt d'être juge jean bazin enfin
ça m'intéressait pas vraiment et vous
aviez vos petits coups de gueule je me
suis les cours de théâtre oui il reste
quelques à regarder
[Musique]
je pense
ma famille
[Musique]
l
académie nous pouvons dans une école
primaire pour débiles mentaux
attendez vous de dentiste hors académie
comme un c pour devenir car si j'ai
compris quelque chose à la chambre
là je vais pas le green de garde je vous
supplie ce n'est pas l'école henri maire
y avait tous les coups
qui a découlé
est-ce que tu les appréhender est ce que
tous les accords et non pas du tout
nogué mais oscar est mon maître mais non
ah ouais non même si ses fins faut
prendre un cours et causse car vous
allez quitter abritait sur sur scène et
apprend quelque chose sur l'intérêt
d'apprendre de gaz sur un
astucieux non encore tous les militaires
tirent de ton corps bien sûr un va être
un autre une autre personne oscar mon
dieu c'est et
vous donnez toujours des causes de terre
dans ce cas toujours toujours toujours
toujours oui on reconnaît dans la rue
aux étoiles comment c était hier
qu'elle élève vous a le plus marqué 20
vraiment qui a été pour vous le d'élèves
clé en fait moi j'aimais les élèves qui
jouaient le jeu avec moi parce qu'après
ils sont plus ou moins tous venus me
voir quand il fallait tourner un film
une émission de télé ou un clip là ils
se sont rendus compte que le mot travail
servi avec intérêt sinon ils sont happés
par le travail de la pierre paquet qui
vous a marqué vous qui vraiment dit j'ai
du mal à dire ça j'ai du mal à dire ça
c'est après cela on prend celui là un
professeur il va il va aimer tout le
monde parce que tout le monde avait un
potentiel latent et puis même ce qu'on
voit moins bien il joue au théâtre il
joue dans des films ils sont à
l'étranger je trouve que chacun fait son
petit chemin et que parfois c'est
discrétion paye parfois plus et c'est
vous non qu'aujourd'hui quoi mais de
faire la star émission comme ça et on
non gevrey du tout je ne peux pas dire
que ça me manque
non quand je vois que d'enseigner ou 1
vous enseignez où j'ai mon école à paris
et je travaille aussi à lille mais a
souvent dû dire au maire je travaille
aussi avec mara stasia gaye pour
révélation des étoiles et on prépare des
gens pour aller à los angeles donc là
qu'il darden school rallye pour
laquelle je fais pendant dix ans le
marrakech du rire avec jamel debbouze au
pays basque après visite surprise pour
vous des bruits je me souvient karine à
l'époque il y avait des fins croyait
énormément en toi et je sais qu'à un
moment pour essayer de 2,2
te créer une sorte de personnage il
voulait à tout prix faire de toiles
anastasia française ah oui c'est vrai je
crois que c'était par rapport à ma voix
est un film si tu leur qu'à l'époque
c'est pas du tout à la mode c'était pas
tout la mode des voix fluette très
visuelle quand on a 16 est arrivé en
fait qu'à se laisser imposer quelque
chose ou satin dans libre jean libre
totalement on m'a franchement marré
m'imposer mais j'avais la semaine
la semaine jerry nodules geste vocal
on lui parle tantôt chantés beaucoup
après déjà deux chiens comme ça
tout en elle alors n'hésitez pas à tous
dans les mêmes dans les mêmes saison
mais est ce que ça vous arrive de vous
revoir de dinan de faire des trucs
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accords très bien filmé à la confinant
a été très bien en fait oui parce que
vous ayez des bizuths renard axes
étaient en a fait un lieu on l'a vu de
certaines menaces à renouer parce que
vrai qu'on s'est un peu perdu en essayer
mais ayez la vie aussi mais voilà il ya
la vie qui a fait ça le confinement il a
fait mais qui n'est pas sur ce fameux
groupe red sox physique et un grand
poids de sac on voulait tous les nanas
qui l'on vous avec saison c'est très
simple nous sur notre par rapport à
notre saison il ya karine mario patrice
jalil mois
olivia ruiz c'est tout non on y vient on
lan téléphone et olivia olivia elle a
voulu décrocher de la star ac dk
l'infini elle a dix mois la star ac ça
m'a permis ça maintenant je fais mon
chemin je veux plus qu'on en parle et
par contre elle ne revient pas sur sa
décision et c'est tout à son honneur
on est un petit peu ce qu'on gagne et
des faits nolwenn à tout ça qu'ils ont
totalement disparu et même je veux dire
la vérité quand on fait un sujet il faut
les floutés oui merci non plus merci à
luis à savourer ça nous choque un peu ce
côté oui oui mais voilà on n'en est plus
à la bande aurait jenifer ou quelqu'un
d'autre on peut prendre n'importe quel
candidat je ne comprends pas si on fait
comme olivia et c'est son choix et je le
comprends tout à fait en dix mois la
star ac' j'en sors on m'en parle plus je
pense que vous serez d'accord avec moi
les copains et on en parle plus par
contre qu'on dise où est la star est bon
alors maintenant je vais être foutu on
m'en parle plus hop et quand le vent est
un peu moins bon a finalement monde est
flouté je regarde à travailler il faut
pas déranger je vais te dire l'agitateur
tam et grâce à mes mois avec ce skin en
effet bénin où les gens savent que je
n'aime pas chanter ne sont pas fous les
gens que tu assez sage et que je ne sais
pas bien tu aies jamais chaque team
connaît bien chez qui je vais à paris
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que il faut pas cracher dans la
saint-louis gt gt le porte-drapeau de la
star ac moi je suis fier je pleure
chaque fois je vois les images vous ne
connaissez tous on ne peut pas dire un
coup oui un coup non c'est ou à la fin
on est fier de ce qu'on a fait a fait
les vingt ans où il n'ya là non je crois
que
j'ai une surprise surtout à propos
d'image j'aimerais parler à jean pascal
parce que c'est vrai que la chance qu'on
a eue sur ses saisons là c'est d'avoir
des personnages comme toi oui mme
georges alain et puis comme d'autres n'a
pas tous les citer là aujourd'hui moi
sur ce que je sais sur la nouvelle star
et qui va arriver c'est que les réseaux
sociaux vont avoir une part très
importante mais avant pendant et après
le rejet coup castet sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est écrit dans les échoppes
leur chanteuse et c'est un peu comme
dans the voice et tous ont déjà ça
est-ce que c'est pas un problème est-ce
que cast et des gens qui sont finalement
déjà un petit peu familiarisé que le
milieu showbiz et c'est parce que les
réseaux sociaux c'est un peu ça est ce
que ce n'est pas un problème pour avoir
des gens comme toi comme il ne s'en soit
you accès aux terminaux sans ça je sais
je pense qu'on peut trouver il faut
c'est là où je signe ce que tu seras
d'accord c'est là où il va falloir qu'il
soit malin sur lequel 6 sur le casting
conrad est vrai je crois qu'il faut
revenir un peu c'est pas de voltaire qui
sait pas il faut pas que des chanteurs
chance très bien il faut des gens qui
savent pas chanter rc gens qui ont
peut-être un talent dans le théâtre les
gens d'en bas il va falloir trouver et
je pense que c'est ça à mon sens qui va
faire que ça va être un bon programme
parce que oui aujourd'hui les gens ils
savent comment ça se passe mais c'est
les deux personnalités fortes rue des
bonnes personnalités vagues énormes ça à
faire flop moi c'est un homme des stars
des stars d'instagram je pense qu'après
tout le monde tourne d'instagram
aujourd'hui tous les réseaux sociaux un
ou deux réseau social donc de toutes
façons des personnes sur faire très bien
comment ça se passe et puis voilà faut
composer avec mais c'est un peu un
passage obligé aujourd'hui mais le hamas
et aurez vous la vérité je n'y crois pas
du tout du tout à la relance de la star
n'est pas du tout et puis même en termes
d'argent ont regagné 1 millions d'euros
alors l expliquer aux gens que c'était
une avance sur recette woods allait
vendre jusqu'à un million d'euros de
disques et puis si vous dépassez ça vous
y avait de l'argent mais aujourd'hui et
du marché du disque après c'est tombé à
500 mhz il faut le dire aussi oui à
200000 parce que savant début
aujourd'hui on va leur offrir coups
gagnants y avait rien à faire appliquer
ça on parle de quoi aujourd'hui y'a rien
qui ait fait non on parle de
suppositions l'astarac elle va peut-être
dans le détail à rennes qui a quitté les
semaines avancent effet si ça se fait je
pense qu'on n'est même pas au courant
des profs du lieu du casting est ce
qu'il y aura de l'argent à gagner est ce
que c est pareil c'est ça dont 4,7 en
organique à une abondance vous dire elle
pour mission dit à quelqu'un on te tente
et tu fais aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
veut vraiment chanter et je vais le
demander à vous qui inquiète chanteur si
à l'époque on vous aurait dit vous
n'avez pas un million d'euros par contre
on vous donne un album vous auriez dit
non et c'est ce qu'il fait avec ceux ci
non mais y en a peut-être pas d'argent
mais on dira tu as la possibilité la
chambre haute ce qu'ils pensaient pince
qui venait on parle d'une émission et je
pense qu'il faut pas tout y penser
ventes de disques et autres parce qu'on
sait que le disque aujourd'hui c'est une
catastrophe et que le plus ce sont les
réseaux sociaux si nous on avait eu les
réseaux sociaux ont fait
multimillionnaire ce serait ce que par
la suite place qu'on vide le blabla
aujourd'hui faut le voir vraiment comme
une émission de divertissement qui
revient une émission familiale vendredi
soir au samedi soir c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le voir qu'est ce que tu chantes
pour les particuliers parfois qui est
tant adorée qui te quitte voilà et pour
départ et pour des gens dont on m'a
demandé de devenir oui faire une
surprise en privé mais ouais ça peut
arriver mais c'est pas mon quotidien
n'était pas de brut est bien sûr et
émaux te tue le seul le cinéma le
théâtre ça marche bien août à mi chemin
entre peu un peu entre parenthèses avec
les marchés juste après on m'a peut-être
avec bernard tapie n'en oui je
oui pendant quelques temps ouais et
après ça en fait j'avais même pas moi je
vous la retourne à l'école j'étais
lycéenne dont je pensais que j'avais pas
la star ac' faire ma tournée est
terminée et la vie a fait que après j'ai
fait du cinéma j'ai fait du théâtre
je suis retourné un petit peu prendre
des cours aussi de théâtre parce que
quand on arrivait quand on sort de la
star ac on n'est pas très bien vu
finalement pas sa sueur du bar garde là
celle-là la blonde en plus qui arrivent
non me regarde un peu de haut donc j'ai
repris un petit peu nourris tous que
nouvelle star avait un peu la carte tu
sortais de nouvelles start avait la
carte tu sortais de star académie ça
sentait pas très bon il